[Music]
[Applause]
before we bring in Brady Quinn the
former NFL quarterback he was on the
pick six podcast and he was on for a
little while but I wanted to give you
just a portion of what seems to have set
off the internet and some former players
in the NFL with what Brady had to say
about CJ Stroud and here's a portion of
that podcast
and then there's some other stuff about
interviews and and maybe you know for
example the Manning Passing Academy I've
been told that you know he committed to
it the night before just kind of ghosted
him didn't show up that's football
royalty and when you do that that's
gonna kind of set off some alarms from
people of like hey man that's not how
you conduct yourself especially around
the Manning family or just in general if
you're gonna be a franchise quarterback
so look I still view him as the second
quarterback that should be taking this
draft class he's the most accurate
quarterback in this draft class he
showcased the athleticism and ability
anytime I've been around the kid he's
been an upstanding young man who's grown
and matured in the leader that I think
um NFL teams are looking for so you know
some of that stuff and as far as the
system he plays in all the talent he
plays around he can't help that he just
can deliver the ball like he has and put
up the numbers that he did so I think
he'll be the number two quarterback
taken but there is some talk right now
and maybe it's smoke screens who knows
that maybe some other teams are saying
well wait a second if Richardson has a
higher ceiling maybe he makes more sense
for us to take if we can't have a guy
like Bryce young that we feel more
confident about in this processing and
decision making and uh to put this in
further context Brady was asked about
you know could CJ Stroud be slipping and
and then the last week There's Been talk
only because Carolina seems to have
focused in on Bryce young therefore CJ
Stroud is slipping well if you're going
from one to two that's not a very far
full or maybe to four and it's typical
around the draft that you start to hear
a lot of things and I thought I'd like
to have Brady join us and maybe put it
into further context here he's on the uh
show that precedes Hours on FOX Sports
Radio 2 pros and a cup of joe the former
Notre Dame quarterback who joins us now
how did this set the internet on fire
Brady
well as you can imagine Dan thanks for
having me on I really thought you would
just have me on because it's meat Friday
and so I thought you were looking to
have a meat stick come on and talk a
little ball or something about the draft
wait wait you called yourself a meat
stick
uh yeah that's what I've been calling at
least I mean that Xbox I think when I
first joined Fox they called me uh beefo
Brady is what they would call me so I've
had to overcome that wow I guess I'm a
good guest in that respect for meat
Friday yeah
um yeah this really became a uh I guess
a firestorm if you will probably about
36 hours ago and it was because someone
had clipped off the clip that you just
played but what they did was they
created a headline that created this
kind of false narrative in regards to
the entire Focus being about the Manning
Passing Academy and CJ Stroud's decision
not to go
uh which was odd because one it wasn't
the first time that we had talked about
that maybe on that podcast but I'm two
pros and a cup of joe we had talked
about that probably a couple of other
times months ago in regards to you know
hey if there's any concerns about CJ
Straub what have you heard either from
Executives people who are within the
industry who are insiders and and so I
kind of brought that up
but of course no one actually listened
to even the clip that you just played
where if you listen to the clip I I
think you could understand then that I
was very complimentary of CJ throughout
both in my impression of him in my
assessment of him uh and I'm pretty sure
either on this show or definitely on big
noon kickoff I'm the guy who said he was
gonna win the Heisman last year so uh it
was a little bit odd to me that there
was such a visceral reaction
to really just a headline and all it
showed me was no one actually listened
to the podcast no one even clicked the
link to listen to the actual quote uh
from that clip and and we can get into
furthermore some of the Dynamics but
rarely the context of even that
conversation before that part of it
we were talking about how could a player
be dropping and why would CJ Stroud be
dropping and so I was I actually
personalized it and talked about you
know my experience going through the
draft and that's why I'm pretty
sensitive to this kind of stuff for a
lot of quarterbacks because it's hard to
overcome stigmas that get attached to
you I mean Dan I'm not sure if you can
believe this but you know I was coming
out I had heard this kind of leading up
to the draft and there was a national
radio show host of time who was like I'm
hearing these two jacked he looks like a
Savage without his shirt on it's
affecting his accuracy you know not sure
if he's to be able to do that I don't
know what national radio show host that
could be but I I remember hearing that
sort of thing and it kind of stuck with
me throughout the course of of my
careers like always two biller too
muscular we've heard that a little bit
about with Will Levis and a kid by the
way because I do believe at some point
you had brought that up in a show at
some point Dan
um but the point is wait wait sense that
I said you were too jacked
uh yeah I may be sensationalizing that a
little bit like we tend to do sometimes
in the media just kind of joking but I
think you would say that someone had set
up no what I was told or whatever no
what I was told was that you weren't
consistent enough in the intermediate
throws
okay and then okay that's something that
could be a comparison but that's a
former quarterback who told me that so
right I stand by that but but no I I
just so
all I'm pointing out is when the muscle
bound thing came up about will Levis
people then start saying well yeah I
just like Brady and I was like okay
um you know let me go back to the
Manning stuff though because
let me finish this point and we'll go
back to it okay but the reason the
reason why I bring that up is because
and I'm sensitive to it because I think
a lot of times First Impressions means
everything in the NFL when you come into
the league especially nowadays with the
way the media Cycle Works you have a
small window and if you have this stigma
attached to you and you can't overcome
that it becomes very hard to overcome
that over the course of your career and
it really blew my mind when I saw the
reaction from people like Ryan Clark uh
like RG3 or even Jalen Ramsey and
quandary Diggs guys who have never I've
never spoke to them
um they don't know anything about me my
work ethic uh film breaks on anything
else and obviously didn't listen to the
clip because even as I talked to Ryan
Clark last night and I think as he heard
it he then kind of realized okay he was
much more complimentary than I realized
so you know I think it became a little
more controversial for a couple of
reasons uh probably because people just
read the headline that's one and the
other because I do think people are
sensitive to and especially when you
have David mulugetta who is CJ Stroud's
agent who's also General Ramsey's agent
who's also Quan J Diggs agent who Ryan
Clark's very comfortable and close to
who's also trying to protect the
reputation of his client the problem
that he needs to worry about is not me
I'm one of his biggest fans the problem
is he needs to worry about other people
who obviously have you know have that
perception for whatever reason and so
again I I don't I don't read a whole lot
into it I didn't really care whether
they went to the Manning Passing Academy
or not but it was something I was told
and I felt like all right like of the
things that if you're if you have
questions about CJ strong what are they
not really many but that was something
that was told to me by a number of
people
but you know how the business works you
know when you say I'm hearing and you
put ghosted the Manning family and you
you know the first family of the NFL and
you know that you could fall because of
that I mean that's that's a juicy
headline that that's made for the week
before the draft and people are going to
run with that and you're right people
don't read or listen to an entire
interview
you know we you know unfortunately we
don't and when you put ghost in the
Manning Academy and you were hearing
well when you hear that's a report
that's Brady Quinn reporting not you
know if I say I'm hearing I'm reporting
I I don't think yeah so I think you're
doing that so you're told by a credible
source that he ghosted the Manning he no
showed at the Manning Passing Academy
correct
yeah that was what I was told okay and
and again and I think our job being in
the media is to take that information
because it's part of our job to say like
what are you hearing if we have people
who are telling us that sort of thing
it's important to say that but it's also
important then to whether that's
credible or not and the reality is
everything I said afterwards discredits
whatever that is
so again I think a lot of us kind of
find ourselves in this fine line of you
know I was fortunate enough but
unfortunate enough where my career
wasn't successful enough but I played
for a lot of different teams and I
crossed paths with a lot of different
players and front office people and
coaches and so when you get to know
people you know obviously you're going
to hear a lot of things but it's your
job in one way is to communicate that
but in the same way I'm also trying to
portray to people that's not a concern
and this young man should be looked at
as the second overall pick or the second
quarterback taken which if Houston
passes on him I I mean those rumors I
don't know what to make of that but
that's also part of the job too
unless people just don't want you to
tell anything and we just say hey well I
think everything's great I think you've
got to be careful on how you frame it
because if I listen and I listen to
about six minutes worth where you talked
about well you're in the system at Ohio
State uh Under Pressure he's not good
um you talked about you well his you
threw it you threw away interviews
you you threw away that that word kind
of floated out there they didn't follow
up on it what happened in the interviews
with the teams because
I I don't know what you heard but you
you made a reference to that
so again is he a bad interview so like
so like the S2 test maybe it wasn't as
good as someone like Bryce young and no
not that he's not that he's been bad
interviews that hasn't been the case at
all
um but in regards to how every one of
these guys conduct themselves there's
differences right and they're all being
compared to one another yeah and it's
more relation to the Carolina Panthers
with the number one overall pick so I
wasn't saying anything different than
anything that's already been said or
reported in that regard because if you
have the number one overall pick with a
team that needs a quarterback they're
comparing all these guys and so you know
as far as Bryce young goes he's blown
everything out of the park there's not
as many reservations about it CJ Stroud
too has done that to it agree there's
just a few people that I've talked to
that there's some concerns there again
not my opinion but what others so that's
part of this whole deal though Dan and
so I don't know how you want like me or
anyone else to do our job when we're
asked a question but we're also trying
to provide our personal opinion of why
whatever we're hearing shouldn't be
right there should be a whole lot that's
read into it
well once again I'll go back to what I
said that you know people take the easy
way out when I hear it then I want to
hear more just to be fair and if I have
a problem that I would say that or
sometimes framing it how you frame it
that's really important with people if
you say look I'm going to tell you some
things I've been told that I don't agree
with
if you state it and it like you are
emphatic sometimes when you're on a
podcast it gets loose you're just
talking it gets loose yes 100 yes and
that's for people and they zero in on
those things and they want to get
something we're leading up to the draft
they're looking for a headline here
no and I understand that and and it
probably could have been framed better I
mean I think I'm using probably more of
the awardage that I was told and so
however you want to portray that right
but when the man in Passing Academy
comes out what June 23rd 26th it was of
2022 and they've got a list of guys and
he's on that list and then he ends up
not being there is that a big deal Brady
is that a big no it's not okay and
that's that's what's crazy about this
okay is for some reason like this caught
fire like it it attacks his character or
whatever else I'm like I I don't care I
I don't think it has any impact and by
the way no one's listening to me or any
other analyst that talks about it and
it's not going to persuade them one way
or another and furthermore this is that
time of year where you get so many
things that are thrown out there that
are smoke screens or don't have any
validity to them just to see how teams
react to them so I again no one's going
to listen to the podcast they're just
gonna you know read a headline and the
hard part is is like you know then it's
like well you got to frame it better
it's like well no I think people should
probably read articles and not just the
title or they should probably listen to
the podcast and not just jump to
conclusion you got to protect yourself
Brady
you do I've said things on this show and
I'm going wait a minute
somebody is grabbing it and running with
it and then you can't it's like you're
trying to catch somebody at the Boston
Marathon you're not catching them and
that's where you got to protect yourself
when you know did you talk to Ryan Clark
Yesterday
it was a good civil conversation you
know I think there's going to be a
difference in how we kind of see some
things but again you know he's someone
that I respect as a former player expect
him when he was a player respect him as
an analyst but I didn't take that
approach to really him or anyone else
right you know that's the thing about
Twitter is everyone wants to kind of
take some some approach to someone they
don't know instead of just reaching out
and calling well Jason Ramsey calls you
out and said you were a bust and you
should have gotten it like that has
nothing to do with this I I would never
question your ability as an analyst
because you didn't you weren't a star in
the NFL like right well and again it's
it's like how do you want to address
that like yeah I know things didn't work
out the way I wanted it yeah I'm glad
they've worked out for him the way
they've wanted him so I've always
thought he's one of the best
quarterbacks in the league okay let me
get this before I run out of time
the one the quarterback you have the
most concerns about on the field who
could be drafted in the first round is
who
well it's it's Anthony Richardson and
it's just because of lack of experience
okay I mean quarterbacking is an
experienced driven position uh he
probably has the most he has the most I
won't say probably he has the most
upside of anyone I don't know that we've
ever seen a quarterback with the
athleticism he has the arm strength
everything and to me like when I go and
uh turn on the Tennessee tape and I
watch him flip his hips and turn around
and deliver a strike a deep curl route I
sit there and go there it is you know
when you see other instances of that
throughout the course the season are in
games there's just some inconsistencies
because he's young at the position but
there's some risks because you know to
me I look at Josh Allen I say everyone
kept saying he was inaccurate it was
come out from Wyoming and it was a poor
argument to be made because they just
look at completion percentage if you
watch the tape on them you're like okay
he's got a live arm the guys he's
throwing to probably you know are having
a hard time coming out of the brakes
picking up the ball catching the ball
but if you give him an offense he's in
for three years if you give him
Supporting Cast around him he's going to
look like a really accurate quarterback
and it just so happened year three he
explodes and they got him stuff on digs
they got him you know he kept him with
Brian dabel the whole time you know
that's the same thing for Anthony
Richardson you know someone like that I
think needs that sort of stability
really all these guys for that matter
but probably him more so than anyone
else you know for that reason so he can
continue to grow and mature in the
position can we take anything out of
context with what Brady said yeah that's
no problem Dan we could do that I'm
gonna go with uh Brady Quinn says the
next Josh Allen is Anthony Richardson oh
okay that's funny because I just heard
him say that he's too inexperienced to
make it at the next level
that's how it works Brady
when I came in it kind of flew over your
head a little bit with that one so
oh no I knew you were talking about me
but I didn't recognize the quote because
I don't remember saying that because
you're too jacked that meant you
couldn't you couldn't be a great thing
Dan is the quotes don't have to be
accurate anymore
right like again in the same one minute
clip you played I'm saying the guy
shooting the second quarterback taking
second overall pick and complimenting
him but no one hears that because no one
actually listens all right meat stick
um have a good weekend all right you
know thank you I'll do my best and don't
skip leg day okay I think you're
spending a little too much time up top
yeah yeah I've heard that once or twice
before you know I think you need like
like uh saquon Barkley thighs you know
you could have been a better quarterback
with saquon Barkley Fox
I I wish I had his size I mean again
that's gonna be taken out oh man I wish
I had his thighs
on meat Friday yeah
you are our meat stick our meat puppet
uh thank you Brady we appreciate it have
a great weekend that's Brady Quinn he
works for Fox Sports
uh